[Musique]
en gros on est en train de scénariser
l'entrée de super beats donc en fait
faire un petit scénario pour pour mon
changement de costume et il y a pas de
la qui est en train de se faire briter
pour pour savoir un peu comment ça se
passait donc c'est lui qui va remplacer
au casque on va tenter on va voir ce que
ça a donné de toute façon avec le kimono
il y a super bien que ça commence avec
beaucoup de costumes ça vous va mettre
Fab en place et lui faire un retour
programme non
[Musique]
on a vu un petit peu dans l'arène on va
y avoir du niveau là parce qu'on va
tenter les embêter c'est pas trop
d'illusions sur l'issue des sur les
résultats non mais je galère déjà avec
mon truc
ça s'annonce bien on va être bien
[Musique]
et bonjour à tous bonjour Alice pot
Paris et on a vu très grand comme vous
pouvez le voir puisque on a rempli
l'arène de personnes
donc pour cette deuxième édition on a
vraiment voulu faire les choses comme il
fallait ouais c'est le flop comme vous
voyez ça flotte complètement à blanc n'a
pas cliqué en plein sur retour sur ma
qu'il en plein travail
merci à tous déjà tous ceux qui sont
venus participer vous allez voir il y a
énormément de monde tous les PC sont
pris on est une centaine de personnes
dans dans la salle
[Musique]
c'est beaucoup trop on va voir la game
du requin
j'ai arraché un pattes alors qu'il avait
besoin de plus je suis trop heureux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
agressif qui marche par le calcul elle a
jamais peur en fait vous prend des
quatre jouets il va y avoir un tour cerf
maintenant qui va arriver pour aller
fixer le pion C6 on a assez des poussées
5 les blancs qui ont forcément
l'avantage il va les bouffer encore un
autre pion et après on verra et après on
verra alors le problème c'est que et le
problème c'est qu'il a donné une pièce
mesdames et messieurs Alexandra vient de
gagner la bécane 2
[Musique]
j'ai toujours plein de notions c'est
plus pour ça on aime
[Musique]